Yeah.
That's how people died.
A lot of people live that way too.
A lot of people live that way until they died.
I mean that.
Do you think about those people that made it across this country and the people
like Lewis and Clark and all of these pioneers,
they just didn't even know what the fuck was around the next corner and they
just walked on through with,
would they have like donkeys with shit on their back?
How much food do you have?
Yeah.
Do you even know what the fuck you're going?
He hit an impasse.
You,
you hike for miles and then you come up to a mountain and you got to double back
and go around this Christ,
no Google earth,
no nothing.
Shit maps and dog shit maps written by people you hope knew what the fuck they
were talking about.
You know,
he'd get maps from native Americans,
get maps from a sailor and try to figure it out,
and then you randomly go into the wrong territory and a Indian Indians want to
kill you.
You know,
there's an interesting,
a film that's out on Netflix right now,
the ballot of Buster Scruggs,
a great movie,
and it's all about that.
It's all about the old west.
It's really weird,
man.
It's so weird.
They're the weirdest guys of all time.
It turns the Kahn brothers.
Yeah.
The Big Lebowski.
You one of my all time favorites.
They've just made so many cool,
weird films,
but this one's really weird.
It's like a bunch of non connected stories.
I thought they were connected,
but they're not.
They just all taking place in the same time period and it's called the old west
and the end.
Pretty similar.
Like they're all fucking dark and you got to go.
Go into it.
I would highly recommend it,
but go into it knowing it's going to be fucking dark.
You've got to go there.
Just accept it.
But Tom Waits,
his one is fucking amazing.
Amazing Dude.
Amazing.
Yeah.
I thought it was Dick Nolton for a second.
Oh yeah,
it was done.
It's multi.
Alright,
dude is so good.
That one.
That one was really good.
The singer guy was really good.
I love that.
He,
well,
I don't want to spoil it.
But now it's,
yeah,
they're all,
they're all great,
but at the end of it,
I was like,
what the fuck did I just watch?
Yeah.